[Musique]
importée qui soulèvent un tonnerre
d'applaudissements acrobaties multiples
danses chansons
le spectacle est au rendez-vous les 218
visiteurs sont sous le charme
la nourriture est parfaite
la chanteuse extra pour l'instant tout
va bien
au matin la suite mais je pense que
c'est très bien on viendra la salle
affiche quasi complet seulement deux
mois après ses débuts le nouveau
spectacle du national palace connaît
déjà un franc succès pour faire face à
une demande record des dates ont été
ajoutées au programme avec un rythme
effréné fantaisie et jouer jusqu'à huit
fois par semaine c'est un petit peu
aussi je pense grâce à notre travail à
c'est déjà la sixième revue est le
public qui revient il revient il revient
à chaque fois comme je disais depuis le
14 septembre c'est pratiquement tous les
mêmes qui sont revenus déjà il ya trois
ans deux ans quatre ans cinq ans tout le
monde revient
certains spectateurs parcours parfois
100 kilomètres pour assister à la
représentation réservent leurs places
plusieurs mois al avance la foule
s'agglutine et à l'entrée du chapiteau
plus d'une demi heure avant l'ouverture
des portes
on profite du départ en retraite et de
l'anniversaire de beau papa pour venir
et découvrir on arrive avec une
association de chez nous voilà on fait
bonne journée est ce qu'un possible
d'obtenir une place d'ici la fin de
l'année
seuls quelques tickets restent
disponibles pour la soirée du nouvel an
mais rassurez vous vous pourrez vous
rattraper en 2020 la campagne de
réservation bat déjà son plein
[Applaudissements]